- I say it almost every day, like.
When I finally go back home, back east,
- [Mark] Yeah.
- People are gonna think I'm lying,
making up stories.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- About some of the
things that happen here.
- [Mark] Where's back east for you?
- Washington, D.C.
- [Mark] D.C.?
- That's why they call me DC.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- Yeah. My kids actually live in Virginia,
but-
- [Mark] Yeah, it's crazy here.
- It never ceases to, like,
I've been here seven years,
and there's still shit that
can happen on a daily basis
that you just couldn't
make, you couldn't make up.
- [Mark] Yeah.
(sighs) DC, so you're
living on the street?
- Yeah, two blocks over, actually.
- [Mark] How long have
you been on the street?
You got a tent?
- Yeah, I got three of them, actually.
- [Mark] Three of them?
- Yeah, actually, today is
our street cleaning day.
- [Mark] Oh, so you're packing it up?
- Yeah, every two weeks
we gotta do that shit.
- [Mark] And then...
So what are you doing to make money?
- I sell pallets.
- [Mark] You sell pallets?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You're resourceful,
that's something different.
- Yeah, and see, 'cause there's, uh,
there's endless supply of them.
You know, you just have
to think of where to go
and when to go there.
And after a while, certain
people will remember you,
certain people will like you,
certain people will don't like you.
You just have to find a way around things,
- [Mark] Yeah.
- to get the pallets.
(DC and Mark laughing)
- [Mark] And then, who
do you sell them to?
- The pallet yards.
There's one, the main
one's here on Series,
right up the street from where I live.
- [Mark] And you gotta
carry the pallet over down?
- Yeah, on a basket,
I push it on a basket,
or a pallet jack or something like that.
- [Mark] Keeps you in good shape.
- Yeah, it does, actually.
Yeah, 'cause you'd be surprised, how...
How...
It's cardio-vascular.
(DC chuckling)
- [Mark] Yeah,
you're in good shape
because of that currently.
- Yeah, whenever I take
a break or some time off
and then I try and do it again,
I get surprised at how
winded I get, tired.
(Mark laughing)
(DC chuckles)
How many breaks I have to take.
Damn, I do shit every day.
Well, yeah, you're right.
- [Mark] So are you using currently?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What are you using?
- Um...
(tongue clicking)
Well, I smoke weed every day,
I smoked weed every day
for most of my life.
Cocaine.
(police siren blaring)
Every once in a while, crystal meth,
but I don't really like it.
Sometimes PCP.
- [Mark] What's, what's the difference?
Did you try heroin too?
- No.
- [Mark] You haven't tried?
- I refuse, I can't...
- [Mark] So what's-
- It's too much dependency on that one.
You have to have it.
- [Mark] But what's the difference?
- Okay.
- [Mark] If someone's gonna take, uh...
Is it crack you're doing?
- Yeah, and powder.
- [Mark] And powder?
- Yeah.
'Cause there's a...
The difference between crack and powder,
it's just the... the urgency of the rush,
which is, it's the same rush.
It's the urgency of the rush.
- [Mark] With the crack it's faster?
- Much more,
much, much more potent
and leaves much, much more, faster.
'cause it's much,
it's uh...
More urgency.
So then...
And then, okay.
And then it's just like, over. (laughing)
So then, it creates another
urgency to keep me going.
- [ Mark] You need more?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And PCP, tell me about that?
- Oh man.
So, I used to smoke that a
lot when I was younger too,
but in D.C, we call it "Love Boat",
or "angel dust" basically.
Over here, it's funny 'cause,
like, this is where they
were getting it, in LA,
it's like LA, DC pipeline, yeah.
So...
I stopped for a long time.
I really-
- [Mark] What does that do for
you, as opposed to cocaine?
- It kills your motor skills.
(Mark laughs)
(DC chuckles)
- [Mark] What's the upside?
- I don't really see one,
I don't remember why I
was smoking. (chuckling)
- [Mark] And crystal
meth? Tell me about that.
- Nothing.
Just nothing.
It's like Tylenol.
Yeah, it's false (indistinct)
You're tired and you don't know it,
you're a zombie.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- At least with cocaine, I...
okay, if you go,
say, another 30 minutes or an hour
without any, and your body catches up,
you're just shutting down entirely,
Crystal meth is more really...
you have to be, like,
knocked out or some shit.
- [Mark] What's the most
popular drug on the street here?
Heroin?
- No, crack.
- [Mark] Crack?
- But crystal meth is catching up,
rapidly. (chuckling)
because some people consider it
like a graduation
because they don't have
to spend as much money.
But it's, it's a false...
See,
I, uh...
I compare it to Tylenol.
Tylenol doesn't really
kill pain or stop pain,
it tricks your brain into
saying there's no pain.
For some people that does work,
I think crystal meth is the same way.
It's tricks your brain,
thinking you're getting a
rush, but you're really not.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood
I'm sure you've talked about it before.
- No, not really, I didn't
open up at all about that.
I don't really do.
I grew up in Chicago.
Uh...
- [Mark] That's where I'm from too,
but in I think I was in
a different neighborhood.
- Probably so.
(Mark laughs)
Where you born in Cook
County Hospital too?
- [Mark] Yeah, I wasn't, no.
- You might've been from like
Naperville, or some shit.
- [Mark] Yeah, exactly (chuckling)
Evanston or Skokie.
(Mark chuckling)
Yeah, and I grew up in Chicago
'till I was 10 years old.
My mom...
She had me,
11 months after, she had my
sister, we had different dads.
She was in college, but she had like...
she had tendencies to
run the streets and do,
do wild stuff.
I remember she used to take us to,
bars and racetracks.
- [Mark] At what age?
- [DC] Four, five...
three, four, five, yeah.
Yeah, and
uh...
Pool halls, racetracks.
Shit like that.
- [Mark] How old was
your mom? At that time.
- [DC] At the time?
- [Mark] She was in her twenties.
- [DC] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
mid twenties, prolly.
She got in trouble, and...
We gotta go to foster care,
me and my sister and my little brother.
- [Mark] You said your mom got in trouble,
did she got put in prison?
- [DC] Yeah.
- [Mark] For what?
- [DC] She still won't let
me know completely, but...
Somebody died. (chuckling)
Yeah,
but, uh...
She ended up being able to get us back.
She got out, she got us back,
and she was a Born again
Christian after that.
Yeah.
But I still remember her,
and, you know, who she is.
Born again Christian stuff, anyway.
(DC sighting)
She got a job transfer,
when I was 10 years old,
to, uh, Washington DC.
She thought it was better,
'cause she's in the building-
The project building I lived in
was a Gangster Disciple control building.
And they started, uh, you know,
they recruit,
like, like boys at a certain age.
And when they see cert-
they saw certain things in
me that they wanted to use.
- [Mark] So the Disciples wanted you?
- [DC] Yeah.
And they wanted to do with
teaching me, and shit.
Good shit.
And she saw it,
she didn't like it.
She figured...
I had to get away.
Ironically, we went to D.C.
D.C. was no better.
That's when I...
was really, really, really cracked out.
- [Mark] The Disciples
were in Chicago or D.C.?
- Yeah, that was in Chicago.
We moved to DC to get away from that.
- [Mark] I see.
- Yeah.
DC was no better.
We didn't know it.
- [Mark] Was there gangs
there? What's wrong?
- No, it's just, just utter poverty.
No so much gangs, it's just...
poverty and poverty.
Especially then, between-
Marion Barry, 'member Marion.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- That was the same year, 1991.
Yeah...
She wanted us to go to better schools.
After like maybe, like, two years,
she had- we moved to Virginia,
Northern Virginia suburbs of D.C.
started a better life, better schools.
And it's where the irony comes in.
That's where I got in all the trouble.
- [Mark] Trouble?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What kind of trouble?
- When I was 13,
I got my first...
When I was 13, was the
first time I smoked weed,
first time I drank, first time I had sex.
First time I bust a gun,
first time I drove a car,
the first, my first felony,
my first charge, period.
First gun charge.
All that shit happened when I was 13.
Yeah, and so, I was a convicted felon,
actually, before I ever had sex.
- [Mark] How much prison time you did?
- In my life?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I mean, I dunno.
(Mark and DC chuckling)
- [Mark] How many-
(DC chuckling)
- [Mark] What have you been in prison for?
- Oh, that (chuckling)
Prison or jail?
- [Mark] Either one.
- Mostly just not doing what they say.
I never really done anything,
like,
so heinous that you
have to be locked away.
It's mostly...
Okay, you know, probation and these rules
- [Mark] You just gotta follow the rules.
- I don't follow any rules.
"We'll give you one more chance."
"You're disrespecting the
judge." All that stuff.
(chuckling)
I gotta problem with authority, I guess.
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- I'll be 38 in two months.
- [Mark] Where exactly do you
see yourself in five years?
- Back with my kids,
with a story to tell,
to help somebody else not do this.
(chuckling)
That's, that's where
I'd like to be in five years.
That's where I will be in five years.
I'll be back with my kids.
And an inspiration to people,
'cause if he can overcome this,
you can overcome anything.
And I know I will overcome this.
- [Mark] This is the bottom, man.
- Yeah!
- [Mark] This is the bottom.
- Yes, this is the hardest way of life.
It's funny, because you think in America
no one would have to live like this.
And most of America has no clue.
And it's really (indistinct)
Only thing is, noticing it, seeing it
doesn't really help you to not do it.
It's very pacified, living on the street,
where you don't have to pay rent,
you don't have to pay any bills.
I mean, the weather permits it.
They bring you food,
bring you clothes.
What else? I mean, what...
Any money you can get,
goes right away on drugs.
It's all right, because
we'll feed you, we'll clothed you.
You can live here for free.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [DC] There's nowhere else like this
anywhere, anywhere.
You can't live on a sidewalk.
(Mark and DC chuckling)
Even if it's summertime,
you gotta hurry up and say
get your ass off the sidewalk.